Do you know what the 8th largest company in
the world is?
You may not be able to guess it off the top
of your head, but you could be pretty sure
that regardless of which company it is, the
brand is probably ubiquitous.
Something like Facebook or JPMorgan Chase
or Alibaba.
But, what if I told you that the 8th largest
company in the word is actually Nvidia.
Now, we all know that Nvidia is a large company,
but no way they’re the 8th largest in the
world.
Don’t they serve a super niche demographic
of gamers and professionals?
Well, you’re right as Nvidia comes in at
rank 386 in terms of revenue pulling in $21.89
billion annually.
But, Nvidia’s profit margins are actually
so high and investors are so bullish on the
future of Nvidia that despite only pulling
in $21.89 billion in revenue, Nvidia is valued
at upwards of a trillion dollars at $757 billion
making them 8th largest company in the world.
To put that in perspective, if Apple was valued
like Nvidia, Apple would be worth $12.65 trillion.
If Apple had such fat profit margins, the
media would be all over it, but with Nvidia,
they don’t bat an eye.
So, here’s how Jensen Huang created a $757
billion cash cow that lurks in the shadows.
JENSEN HUANG
Taking a look back, Jensen Huang was born
on February 17, 1963 in Tainan City, Taiwan.
Jensen spent many of his early years in Taiwan,
but when he turned 9 years old, his family
would immigrate to Kentucky.
In Kentucky, Jensen and his brother attended
a Baptist boarding school called Oneida Baptist
institute.
But, this didn’t last that long as his family
would move to Oregon and Jensen would end
up attending Aloha high school.
From a very young age, Jensen was quite an
overachiever and his specialties were academics
and table tennis.
When he was 15 years old, he placed third
in junior doubles at the US table tennis open
championship.
Anyway, Jensen graduated in 1980 and he would
find himself at Oregan state university where
he majored in electrical engineering.
At Oregon state, Jensen’s lab partner was
a woman named Lori, and these two would eventually
get married.
After graduating in 1984, Jensen would score
a job at a young startup called LSI Logic.
The company was just founded 3 years before
his graduation, so Jensen was able to secure
a high level position as director straight
out of college.
He didn’t stick around for long though as
he would jump to AMD and become a microprocessor
designer.
At this point, an outsider would think that
Jenson was killing it, and objectively he
was.
He had a solid job at AMD and he was presumably
building his relationship with Lori.
Jensen was clearly way ahead of the average
broke college graduate, but Jensen wasn’t
actually that happy.
Jensen was having some sort of early life
crisis in his late 20s, and he longed to do
something that was much bigger.
He suppressed this feeling throughout most
of his 20s, but eventually he gave in and
took the plunge.
In 1990, Jensen returned to school to get
his masters in electrical engineering from
Stanford.
And after graduation, he co-founded a startup
with Curtis Priem and Chris Malachowsky.
NV
The trio had no clue what to name the company
or how exactly they were going to fund development,
but one thing they were sure of from the very
beginning was that they were going to produce
GPUS or graphics processing units.
They felt that video games created some of
the world’s most computationally challenging
problems, and if they could solve video games,
they could solve nearly any computing problem
out there.
Aside from offering a great challenge, video
games offered a massive opportunity.
Gaming was just in its infancy and the original
playstation hadn’t even come out yet.
So, there was plenty of growth left, but the
problem was that these three weren’t the
only ones trying to capitalize on this upcoming
boom.
By 1994, there were already over two dozen
graphics card companies and this number would
balloon to over 70 by 1997.
Despite the significant competition, one of
the best and worst parts of the semiconductor
industry is that brand value doesn’t mean
all that much.
Unlike Apple and Microsoft who can afford
to be complacent for years and sometimes even
decades, being complacent in the semiconductor
industry results in a pretty quick demotion
from number 1 regardless of how established
you are.
I mean just take a look at Intel.
They’re getting obliterated by AMD, and
they haven’t set an all time high in 21
years.
On the brightside, this meant that Jensen
could easily break into the market if he created
a superior product.
The problem though is that it’s not actually
that easy to create said product especially
when you only have $40,000.
Despite the difficulty and low budget, the
trio got to work on iterating through gpus
which they called NV.
NV simply stood for next version, and it wasn’t
until they incorporated the company that they
came up with a name for the company itself.
Given that they were naming all of their prototypes
NV, they felt that it was only fitting to
find a name that started with NV for the company.
They never found such a word, but they did
find the Latin word “invidia” which translates
to envy.
They simply dropped the i and that’s how
Nvidia was born.
Anyway, about a year after founding the company
and many years of working on the product,
the trio was ready to launch their first product.
In 1994, Nvidia formed a partnership with
electronic manufacturer SGS Thompson and Diamond
Multimedia Systems to produce the NV1.
SGS was tasked with manufacturing the chip
itself and Diamond Multimedia was tasked with
installing the chips onto multimedia accelerator
boards.
The NV1 would launch in 1995 as the Diamond
Edge 3D, and it didn’t take long for video
game companies to leverage the hardware.
Sega became the first to port a 3d game called
Virtual Fighter onto the new gpu.
Over the next few years, Nvidia would form
a couple of partnerships and launch a few
bits of software and hardware, but their biggest
release by far was in 1999.
In 1999, Nvidia launched the GeForce 256 which
they like to call the world’s first GPU.
This doesn’t really mean much though given
that they invented the term themselves.
Nvidia defined GPU as a single chip processor
that could process a minimum of 10 million
polygons per second.
To put that in perspective, modern GPUs are
able process 7 billion polygons per second.
So, there was still a long way to go, but
this is where it all started.
SURVIVING THE PURGE
Before Nvidia could focus on reaching those
insane numbers though, they needed to focus
on survival because the dotcom crash was rolling
around.
Nvidia was founded right before the dotcom
bubble really started to pick up steam, so
they’re rise up was like a rocketship.
But, now it was time to see if Nvidia could
reach orbit or if they would crash back to
Earth.
The dotcom crash didn’t initially impact
Nvidia as they were more of a background player
as opposed to a consumer brand.
In fact, Nvidia was named the fastest growing
company in America in 2002.
Ironically, Nvidia would get crushed that
same year.
Within just 12 months, Nvidia would crash
90% and nearly return to IPO levels.
To make things worse, Curtis Priem would retire
from Nvidia the following year, so it was
up to Jensen and Chris to lead the company
through the wreckage.
Jensen started off by acquiring some discounted
companies including 3dfx and mediaQ.
But, Nvidia’s biggest development during
this time was no doubt SLI.
Nowadays, SLI is mostly a joke and there’s
very little use for it, but back in 2004,
this was a game changer.
SLI or Scalable Link Interface allowed for
multiple GPUS to work together and produce
a singular output.
If you had two GPUS in SLI, each GPU would
render alternating frames, so the workload
of each GPU was cut in half.
Now, this didn’t mean that the system was
twice as powerful as a single GPU, but it
was a substantial improvement.
Also, this invention resulted in gaming enthusiasts
to buy multiple GPUS each time they built
a PC, so it was quite lucrative.
Aside from SLI, Nvidia also formed a handful
of strategic partnerships.
In 2004, Nvidia formed a partnership with
NASA where they helped NASA reconstruct the
terrain of Mars using Nvidia GPUS.
That same year, Nvidia would also team up
with Blizzard Entertainment to create 3d graphics
for World of Warcraft.
Nvidia followed up these great partnerships
with the nail in the coffin which was a partnership
with Sony on the PS3 in 2005.
With all of these acquisitions, partnerships,
and SLI, Nvidia was able to survive the dotcom
crash.
Remember how there were 70 companies in 1997
targeting the GPU market?
Well, by 2006, Nvidia was the only independent
GPU company that was still standing.
It seemed like it was just blue skies ahead,
and Forbes would name Nvidia as the company
of the year in 2007.
And then the 2008 financial crisis rolled
around.
I don’t know what it is but these publications
are perfect at calling the top.
After Fortune named Nvidia the fastest growing
company of the year in 2002, Nvidia crashed
90%.
After Forbes named Nvidia the company of the
year, 2008 happened.
Fortunately though, 2008 wasn’t nearly as
bad as the dotcom crash for Nvidia.
In terms of stock price, Nvidia crashed 85%,
but fundamentally the company was much stronger.
The company did have a couple of negative
quarters, but they were back up on their feet
by 2010, and that brings us into modern day
Nvidia.
MODERN DAY NVIDIA
Throughout the first half of the 2010s, Nvidia
was more or less stagnant.
Their revenue and profits didn’t change
all that much, and the company wasn’t really
growing.
This wasn’t really their fault though as
they had simply reached market saturation,
and they needed the market itself to grow
larger before they could grow again.
Fortunately for Nvidia, the market would not
only grow but it would explode in 2016 and
17 due to cryptocurrencies.
As y'all probably know, Bitcoin made a mad
dash to $20,000 and took all the altcoins
with it to the moon in 2017.
And graphics cards happened to be perfect
for cryptocurrency mining and especially ethereum
mining.
Miners ate up the GPU market as they were
willing to pay anything to get their hands
on GPUS.
Double, triple, quadruple the price, miners
didn’t care.
They were making thousands if not tens of
thousands from their mining rigs, and paying
a premium to get a GPU was not a problem.
Nvidia saw a supply shortage like never before,
and they were able to jack up prices through
the roof.
Between 2016 and 2018, Nvidia’s quarterly
profits jumped from $200 million a quarter
to $1.2 billion per quarter, but this was
just the beginning.
Given that Nvidia had reached market saturation
with gamers, Jensen was shifting his focus
to other markets which led him to deep learning
and AI.
They formed a partnership with Tesla and provided
them with the initial hardware for self driving.
They also launched a bunch of commercial cards
like that titan and quadro that appealed to
institutional buyers.
Just as bitcoin was blowing up and their expansion
efforts were paying off, AMD was resurrecting
the stagnant PC gaming community.
The launch of Ryzen CPUS made PCs much more
affordable which attracted a lot of console
gamers.
By the end of 2018 and throughout 2019 though,
the effects of these catalysts were starting
to wear off, but then 2020 and the supply
shortage hit, and Nvidia was sent on another
rocketship and they haven’t gotten off yet.
CONCLUSION:
Today, Jensen stands at $27.9 billion which
makes him part of the top 100 richest people
in the world.
Looking forward, it’s not clear how much
more Nvidia can grow in the imminent future
as they’ve already ballooned 129% over the
past year.
But as long as Jensen is CEO, I think it’s
just a matter of time until Nvidia recovers
from the next setback and becomes a trillion
company.
And then, Nvidia will be the trillion dollar
shadow company.
Do you guys own an Nvidia GPU?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you’re still waiting
for GPU prices to go down.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.